สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับทุกคนนะคะสู่ห้องเรียน
comprehensible  Thai ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ในวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครู
ชิมาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะในวันนี้วัน
อะไรคะูชิวันนี้วันพุธค่ะอ่าวันพุธวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะ 31 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
มกราคมค่ะค่ะปีพ.ศหรือ
พุทธศักราช
2567 ค่ะค่ะปีคริตศักราชหรือพเอ่อค.ศคะ
ค.ศ
2024 ค่ะค่ะนะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กครูชิมาพบกัน
ในวันสุดท้ายของเดือนมกราคมเป็นวันพุธนะ
ตรงกับวันพุธวันที่
31 เดือนมกราคมปีพุทธศักราช
2567 คริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะอือื
นะวันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันพุธเนี่ยเป็นวันเอ้อ
วันพุธต้องเป็นวันดีอืเป็นวันที่เราต้อง
คุยเกี่ยวกับเรื่องการกิน
ค่ะคือจริงๆแล้วอ่ะประเทศไทยเนี่ยเราก็
ได้รับชื่อเสียง
ที่โด่งดังเรื่องเกี่ยวกับเรื่องกินค่ะนะ
ไม่ว่าจะมีของกินเนี่ยถ้านักเรียนมา
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยเรามีของกินเนี่ย 24 ชมง
ค่ะคือทั้งวันทั้งคืนนะคุณอยากกินหิวตอน
ไหนกินได้ค่ะไม่มีเวลาแบบปิดเปิดอะไรแบบ
นี้คือมันจะมีร้านที่เปิดกลางคืนร้านที่
เปิดกลางวันเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยแล้วก็มีทั้ง
ที่เปิดทั้งทั้งกลางวันแล้วก็กลางคืนด้วย
อย่างอมเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราจะกินเนี่ยตอน
เวลากี่โมงก็กินได้ค่ะนะแล้วก็หลายๆเมนู
ในอาหารไทยครูปุ๊กเป็นที่ชื่นชอบของชาว
ต่างชาตินะคะอย่างอันนี้เนี่ยอันนี้ถือ
ว่าเป็นเมนูไทยที่ติดอันดับนะอก็ในแต่ละ
ปีไม่เหมือนกันเห็นมอย่างนี้นี่ๆๆๆติด
อันดับหมายถึงว่าเวลามีการแข่งขันหรือ
ประกวดเนาะเพราะว่ามีคนเนี่ยชอบเอาของกิน
เ่ะมาคิดว่าใครประเทศไหนอร่อยที่สุดอะไร
อร่อยอะไรแบบนี้นะแล้วก็เมนูของประเทศไทย
เนี่ยจะได้รับมาอยู่นะอยู่ในอันดับแบบ
ท็อปเบางทีท็อปไทนะตลอดค่ะถูต้องนะคะอัน
นี้เนี่ยนักเรียนบางคนอาจจะจะรู้จักหรือ
บางคนอาจจะไม่รู้จักอันนี้เราเรียกว่าแกง
พแนงนะคะอันนี้เนี่ยติดอันดับ 1
ค่ะประเภทอาหารที่เป็น
ศัตรูอันนี้ปี
อ๋อก็ปีที่แล้วนี่เองนะนะใช่ของ Test  at
Last นะจัดอันดับประเภทแกงศัตรูเป็น
อาหารที่มีน้ำำซุปแบบเป็นแกงเนี่ยพแนง
เนี่ยมาเป็นอันดับ 1 อือนะคะรสชาติมันก็
จะแบบหวานๆเค็มๆแล้วก็มีเผ็ดนิดๆ
ออ่ะแล้วก็มีมัดสมั่นค่ะนะคะมัดสมั่นอัน
นี้นะติดอันดับ 1 ค่ะอันนี้เป็นเมนูอาหาร
ที่ดีที่สุดปี
221 อ่าแต่คนละเว็บไซต์เนอะ
ใช่ CNN  Travel อ่า
อันนี้แกงมัดสมันซึ่งตอนนี้ก็ยังอร่อย
อยู่นะคะหรือแม้แต่อันนี้ค่ะหลายๆคนรู้
จักนะ
คะส้มตำอือหือส้้มตำนี่ติดอันดับ 6
ประเภทเมนูสลัดอ๋อเขาจัดอันดับเป็นแยก
อย่างนะว่าอ๋ออันนี้เป็นแบบแกงอันนี้เป็น
แบบสลัดอันนี้เป็นแบบเส้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวหรือ
อะไรแบบนี้ใช่มั้ยมอ่อก็จากเว็บไซต์เดิม
นะปีที่แล้วนะคะ
2023 หรืออันนี้ค่ะนักเรียนบางคนอาจจะ
ไม่รู้จักนะเราเรียกว่าผ้ากุ้งเอากุ้ง
เนี่ยมาเอ่อใส่อะไรนะตะไคร้ซอยแบบกุ้งอัน
นี้ก็อยู่ในกลุ่มเมนูสลัดเหมือนกันเหมือน
เหมือกลุ่มส้มตำแต่อันนี้ได้อันดับ
6 นะคะเห็นมยออหน้ากุ้งอันดับ 9 ใช่มย
เอออันดับ 9 แล้วก็ส้มตำอยู่อันดับ 6 ส้ม
ตำอันดับ 6
ออแล้วก็อันนี้ค่ะนักเรียนรู้จักกันมายาว
นานค่ะใช่
โอโหต้มยำกุ้งอันนี้เนี่ยอยู่ใน 20
อันดับโลกนะ
อ่าเป็นเมนูซุป
นะ CNN เวลเหมือนกันต่อมาค่ะเป็นเครื่อง
ดื่มบ้างโอโหโอเมนูอาหารยังไม่หมดค่ะ
เหลือผัดไทย
อ่าเอผัดไทยเนี่ยติดอันดับ 4 ครูปุ๊กโอ้
นะเป็นอาหารที่คนชอบนะแล้วก็สั่งผ่าน
delivery นะในอเมริกาใน
อเมริกา
ออตั้งของปีที่แล้วนะติดอันดับ 4 เอันนี้
น่าจะไปเช็คจากว่าคนที่โทรศัพท์ลิเวอรี่
นะแล้วก็สั่งอะไรมากที่สุดแล้วก็ติด
อันดับที่ 4 ของอเมริกานะน่าจะเป็นต่อมา
เครื่องดื่มค่ะครูปุ๊กเครื่องดื่มชาไทย
ค่ะอืมอร่อย
ค่ะอันนี้จัดเป็นเครื่องดื่มติดใน 1 ใน 20
นะอันดับเครื่องดื่มที่ไม่มีแอลกอฮอล์ปี
ที่แล้ว
อืนะอร่อยค่ะ
อร่อยแล้วก็อันนี้ค่ะขาดไม่
ได้ต้องมีแน่นอนนั่นก็คือข้าวเหนียว
มะม่วงค่ะอืนะประเภทอาหารและขนมยอดนิยม
2022 อือนะติดอดับเหมือนกันนะนักเรียนจะ
กินมะม่วงให้อร่อยต้องมาฤดูร้อนของเรานี่
แหละเดี๋ยวมีนาคเมษายนเนี่ยนะมะม่วงจะ
อร่อยเยอะค่ะแล้วก็อันนี้ค่ะเราเคยทำคลิป
ปลาท่องโก๋กินกับอะไรรก็อร่อยใช่ๆๆติด
อันดับ 5 ของหวานสตต Food ที่ดีที่สุดใน
โลกปี 2023 ค่ะโอ้นะเพราะว่าปลาทั้งโก
เนี่ยกินกับกาแฟก็อร่อยกินกับชาก็อร่อย
กินกับโจ๊กเป็นอาหารเช้าก็อร่อยนะกินกับ
อะไรก็อร่อยจิ้มนมข้นหวานก็อร่อยอ้าถ้า
นักเรียนอยากรู้ว่ากินกับอะไรอร่อยเนี่ย
เราเคยทำคลิปไปใช่มยใช่
ค่ะ
อื้อหือพูดถึงของกินตั้งแต่เช้าอีกแล้วะ
คูชิเนี่ยทำให้ครูปุ๊กปุ๊กเนี่ยหิวเลยแต่
ครูปุ๊กรู้มั้ยคะปีนี้เนี่ยเรามีการจัด
อันดับนะคะแล้วก็มีเรื่องของการมีอาหาร
เมนูต่างๆที่ที่ติดอันดับนะคะอันเนี้ยไม่
ได้จัดอันดับเป็นประเภทนะเค้ามีการจัด
อันดับเป็นอาหารที่คนโหวตให้อันดับหนึ
เนี่ยเป็นของบราซิลแต่เราจะพูดถึงอาหาร
ไทยนะอาหารไทยของเราเนี่ยติดหลายเมนูค่ะ
มีอยู่ 5 เมนูด้วยกันครูปุ๊กโอคือเอา
อาหารแต่ละประเทศมาแล้วก็ให้คนเนี่ยโหวต
เลือกว่าชอบอะไรมากที่สุด
ใช่มยแล้วก็เอาจำนวนเนี้ยมาจัดอันดับว่า
นะโหวตให้ประเทศไหนใช่มยทั้งหมดกี่เมนู
อ่ะเค้าเลือกมามั้ยเค้าบอกมั้ยหรือว่า 100
เมนูค่ะอื 100 เมนูแล้วก็แยกออกไปอันดับ 1
-  100 เนี่ยมีของประเทศไหนบ้างแต่มี 5
เมนูของไทยติด 1 ใน 100 เมนูค่ะมีอะไร
บ้างคะอันแรกนี่แน่นอนค่ะนะคะนักเรียนก็
รู้จักครูปุ๊กก็รู้จักเป็นอาหารที่ใครๆก็
รู้จัก
อ่าอาหารที่กินง่ายนะคะ
อกระเพราค่ะผัด
กระเพราไข่าวด้วยค่ะเอหน่ากินมากูชิ
นะเวลากะเพราเนี่ย
ติดอันดับค่ะติดอันดับเอ่อต้องบอกว่าติด
อันดับเมนูที่คนไทยบอกว่าถ้าเราคิดอะไร
ไม่ออกก็กินอันนี้แหละมันง่ายไงนะคะติด
อันดับ
3 โอหนะได้ 3 คะแนนโหวตสูงสุด
4.73
อ่าชนะเมนู
พิซซ่าแซงเมนูพิซซ่าของอิตาลีนะเพราะว่า
เมนูพิซซ่าเนี่ยอยู่อันดับ
4 นะคะออแล้วก็เอ่อเป็นรองเมนูโรตีของ
มาเลเซียโรตีคานของมาเลเซียนะอันนั้นเขา
เป็นอันดับ 2 อันดับ 1 เนี่ยก็เป็นเมนู
ของบราซิลค่ะพิกแคนหญ้านะฮกะเพราเนี่ย
อยู่อันดับ 3 แล้วอันดับต่อไปล่ะคะครูชิ
อันดับต่อไปเนี่ยก็จะเป็นเรื่องของเอ่อ
อาหารอันดับ 6 อืมที่ของใครนได้อันอันดับ
6 เป็นเมนูไทยค่ะที่ได้ชื่อมานะคะนั่นก็
คือ
นะข้าวข้าวซอย
อ่าข้าวซอยค่ะ
โออันนี้ค่ะข้าวซอยเนี่ยเป็นอาหารที่ครู
บุ๊กชอบมากเลยครูชิโดยเฉพาะข้าวซอยไก่นะ
เพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วข้าวซอยมันมีทั้งข้าว
ซอยหมูข้าวซอยเนื้อวัวนะแต่ครูปุ๊กก็ชอบ
ที่สุดข้าวซอยไก่ค่ะอร่อยมากคือแต่เดิม
เนี่ยเค้ามีข้าวซอยเนื้อไก่กับเนื้อวัว 2
อย่างแต่ปัจจุบันเนี่ยมีเนื้อหมูด้วยมี
ข้าวซอยทะเลด้วยมีข้าวซอยสำหรับคนที่ไม่
กินเนื้อก็เป็นข้าวซอยเต้าหู้ด้วย
อออย่างั้นสำหรับคนกินมังสวิรัตก็กินได้
เป็นข้าวซอยเต้าหู้เอออร่อยค่ะอร่อยู
การันตีค่ะแต่ข้าซอยนะคะเอ่อจัดอยู่ใน
ประเภทที่เป็น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวถ้าเป็นประเภทก๋วยเตี๋ยวเนี่ย
ติดอันดับ 1 ของโลกค่ะว้าวที่อร่อยเอแต่
อร่อยจริงนักเรียนแล้วเป็นเป็นก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ที่เป็นเส้นสีเหลืองนะเราเรียกว่าบะหมี่
นะแต่ในภาษาเหนือเขาเรียกเป็นข้าวซอย
อ่าจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยข้าวซอยเนี่ยเป็นอาหาร
พื้นเมืองก็คือเป็นอาหารที่กินกันอยู่ทาง
ภาคเหนือของประเทศไทยเขาเรียกอันนี้ว่า
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวห้ออืนะจริงๆแล้วได้อิทธิพลก็
คือส่งต่อมาจากชาวจีนยาหรือพวกห้อนั่น
แหละนะคจริงๆก็มีลักษณะเป็นบะหมี่นะเขาค
ก็เลยไปถูกจัดอยู่ในกลุ่มของบะหมี่ที่
อร่อยที่สุดนะคะแต่ตอนที่มาในประเทศไทย
อ่ะน้ำซุปเค้าเป็นน้ำซุปใสๆค่ะครูปุ๊กก็
คือก๋วยเตี๋ยวอืก๋วยเตี๋ยวแล้วก็มีน้ำซุป
แต่มีเครื่องแกงไงรดจะรถจัดจ้านแต่ไม่ได้
ใส่
กะทิมันมาถูกใส่กะทิตอนที่มาเป็นอาหาร
ไทยยคนไทยก็ดัดแปลงบอกว่ารสชาติเก่าเนี่ย
มันไม่อร่อยเติมกะทิเข้าไปกลายเป็นแบบ
อร่อยไปเลยแล้วก็เป็นที่ติดอกติดใจของคน
อื่นๆมากมาย
นะหลายๆคนก็ชอบเนาะเพราะว่าพอมันใส่กะทิ
เนี่ยมันมีความเป็นมันๆอร่อยค่ะแล้วก็มี
ความหอมนะุูปุ๊กก็
ชอบทีเนี้ยที่เค้าเรียกว่าข้าวซอยเพราะ
ว่าเค้าทำมาจากแป้งสาลีแป้งข้าวสาลีค่ะ
แล้วก็ใส่น้ำใส่ไข่แล้วก็นวดวแล้วเก็รีด
ให้เป็นแผ่นบางๆแล้วก็มาซอย
นะคือมันจะมีการหั่นใช่มั้ยมีมีดแล้วก็
หั่นหั่นเนี่ยมันจะช้าๆถ้าซอยเนี่ยมันจะ
ละเอียดกว่า
นะ
อ่าก็ขึ้นอยู่กับฝีมือของแต่ละคนนะว่า
เอ่อซอยได้ได้เอ่อละเอียดแค่ไหน
ใช่มยทีเนี้ยเออครูชิมีวิธีการทำข้าวซอย
นิดหน่อยให้ดูอจัดมาค่ะนี่ค่ะูปุ๊กเห็นมย
เห็นแล้วค่ะนี่เาจะมีแป้งสาีนะเสร็จแล้ว
ก็ใส่ไข่
อ่า
นี่ทำเหมือนเราสามารถทำให้มันเร็วๆกว่า
นี่ใส่ไขลงไปค่ะตึ๊บๆๆๆๆในปริมาณอันที่
ต้องการแล้วก็นวดกันเข้าไป
ค่ะย้ำๆๆๆเนี่ยอ่าแล้วก็นวดให้แป้งเหมือน
เหมือนนักเรียนทำขนมปังอ่ะเนาะนะแล้วก็
คลุกเคล้ากันแล้วก็นวดแป้งกับไข่ให้เข้า
กันแล้วก็เติมน้ำลงไป
อ่าเติมน้ำที่แบบน่าจะมีนมันด้วยนะเพไม่
ให้มันเพื่อให้มันไม่ติดกันมากนะคะจน
กระทั่งแบบนวดจน
เป็นก้อนแป้งนวดจนเป็นก้อนแป้งแล้วก็มา
รีดนี่อันนี้ใช้ไม้ใช้ไม้นวดนะเค้ามีวิธี
การใช้ไม้แบบนวดให้เนื้อมันเข้ากันอันนี้
เวลาเทำเยอะๆใช่มั้ยทำเยอะๆ
นะ
[เพลง]
นี่นวดจนแบบเข้ากันหมดแล้วนะคะก็จะมาหัก
สมัยก่อนจะมารีดเป็นแผ่นแล้วก็ซอยค่ะก็
เลยเรียกว่าเข้าซอยแต่ปัจจุบันนี้เรามี
เทคโนโลยีมากขึ้นใช่มยอาฮะเราก็เอามานี่
เาจะผ่านการรีดใช่มยนี่อันนี้มีเครื่อง
รีดให้มันแบนๆคือไม้นั่นเองคืออย่างของ
นักเรียนก็จะมีไม้นวดขนมปังใช่มยนี่คุ
ปุ๊กเห็นขวามือหรือเปล่านี่ก็มีเครื่อง
รีดแบบนี้อ่าปัจจุบันเขาก็มีเทคโนโลยี
เพิ่มขึ้นมานิดหน่อยแบบชบ้านชาวบ้านนะ
สมัยก่อนก็ใช้ไม้ค่ะนวดเอานะคะคืออาจจะ
ขายไม่ได้เยอะมากไงคุชิถ้าเกิดขายเยอะๆ
น่าจะต้องใช้เครื่องใหญ่กว่านี้อ่าอ่ารีด
ไปรีดมารีดไปรีดมาหลายๆรอบเพื่อให้เนื้อ
แป้งเนี่ยมันแน่นอัดแน่นกันเข้าไป
นะเสร็จแล้วพอได้แป้งแบบเค่ะแล้วมาซอยแต่
เดี๋ยวนี้ก็มีเครื่องตัดก็เลยเอาเครื่อง
ตัดมาตัดแทนไงมันจะลดเวลาลงนะแล้วก็ใช่
เวลาก็จะไม่ต้องใช้เยอะนี่จะมีใบมีดตัด
เห็นมั้ยคะอืใส่เข้าไปค่ะแล้วก็ขนาดก็จะ
เท่ากันด้วยไม่ต้องใช้มีดซอยแล้วอันนี้จะ
เรียกเข้าซอยอยู่มยก็ก็ซอยโดยการ
ใช้โดยการใช้เครื่องมือค่ะนก็ยังต้อง
เรียกเหมือนเดิมค่ะครูชิเพราะว่าภาษาเนาะ
มันก็ไม่เปลี่ยนไงถึงวิธีการอาจจะเปลี่ยน
นะไม่ได้ใช้มีดซอยแบบึดๆๆๆๆๆๆนะแต่ก็ยัง
ยังต้องใช้ลักษณะเหมือนเดิมค่ะทำให้มัน
เป็นเส้นเหมือนเดิมนะก็เรียกว่าข้าซอย
อยู่ดีแล้วอือหือทีนี้ถ้าพูดถึงเอ่อข้าว
ซอยใช่มยว่าข้าวซอยเนี่ยเราก็จะต้องมีค่ะ
เครื่องแกงค่ะครูกุ๊ก
อ่าใช่ค่ะเพราะนักเรียนจะเห็นสีออกแดงๆ
ส้มๆเนาะนะนั่นคือพริกค่ะพริกแต่ไม่ใช่
พริกอย่างเดียวค่ะเราเรียกว่าเครื่องแกง
แสดงว่าต้องใส่หลายๆอย่างค่ะนะคะเครื่อง
แกงของเราเนี่ยนี่ค่ะ
โอโหตำน้ำพริกเข้าไปต้องใช้ต้องใช้ครกหิน
นะ่นักเรียนจะเห็นอันนี้คือเปลือก
มะกรูดลูกเขียวๆแล้วก็เอาแต่เปลือกมาแล้ว
ก็มี
ตะไคร้มีพริกแห้งมีกะปิมีโอ้โหเยอะค่ะ
ปัจจุบันมีแบบขายไม่ต้องไปตำเองแล้วมี
สำเร็จใช่นักเรียนไปซื้อเนี่ยจะบอกเขาว่า
เอาอะไรคะซื้ออะไรคะครูชิคือปกติเราก็จะ
เอ่อข้าวซอยใช่มเราก็บอกเครื่องแกงข้าว
ซอยเดี๋ยวนี้เจะทำแบบเครื่องแกงเฉพาะมา
เลยอ่ะเครื่องแกงส้มเครื่องแกงเผ็ด
เครื่องพะแนงเครื่องมัสมั่นแบบมีสำเร็จ
ขายแล้วค่ะครูปุ๊กเดี๋ยวนี้ง่ายเหลือเกิน
ค่ะนะคะทีนี้วิธีการทำค่ะก็มีหม้อนะบาง
บางทีใช้หม้อดินก็โอเคนะอ่ามันจะหอมกว่า
มัู้ชินะแล้วก็เอากะทิเนี่ยใส่ลงไป 1
ถ้วย
อต้องเป็นหัวกะทินะก็คือน้ำแรกของเวลาเรา
คั้นมะพร้าวออกมานะน้ำที่ 1 เนี่ยเป็นหัว
กะทินะเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยก็ใส่ลงไปค่ะแล้วก็
เอาเครื่องแกรงเครื่องแกรงมาใส่เข้าไปเรา
ชอบเผ็ดมากเผ็ดน้อยเราก็ใส่ตามปริมาณที่
เราชอบค่ะอืออ่าส่วนมากเนี่ยคนไทยก็จะไม่
กินรสอ่อนๆนะต้องใส่แบบจัดๆหน่อยก็คือ
ต้องใส่พริกแกงเยอะหน่อยอือหือนี่เห็นม
นะอันนี้ก็คือใส่ลงไปในกะทินะแล้วก็ผักด
ใชจนมันแบบเ้าเรียกว่าแตกมันแตกแตกมัน
คือกะทิเจเปลี่ยนเป็นน้ำมันใช่นะก็มาจาก
น้ำมันมะพร้าวนี่แหละนะเพราะว่าเวลามัน
แตกแล้วมันก็จะเป็นแบบสีเป็นน้ำมันลอย
ขึ้นมาแล้วก็อยู่กับพริกแกงอื้อหือเห็น
มั้ยคะจะมีน้ำมันสีแดงๆแกงมันจะเป็นสีส้ม
ๆใช่มั้ยแต่จะมีน้ำมันเยิ้มๆเป็นสีแดง
เนี่ยอยู่ที่ด้านหน้าเสร็จแล้วเราใส่ผง
กะหรี่
อไม่ใช่ผงกะหรี่อะไรนะเอ่อผงกะหรี่ที่แบบ
เราสำหรับผัดอะไรนะผัดผัดปูผัดผงกะหรี่
อ่าผงกะหรี่สีเหลืองๆนะเป็นเครื่องเทศนะ
เอามาละลายน้ำเล็กน้อยแล้วก็มาใส่เมีเ้า
มีขายเป็นซองๆค่ะนักเรียนไปซื้อผงกะหรี่
แล้วก็ตัดแล้วก็เอามาตักแล้วก็ใส่ผสมน้ำ
อืเพราะนั้นแกงมัสมเอ้ยไม่ใช่แกงเออข้าว
ซอยเนี่ยนะคะมันก็เลยจะมีสีออกส้มๆเหลือง
ๆนะใช่นี่พอเสร็จแล้วเราก็ใส่เนื้อ
ไก่ลงไป
ผัดตุ๋นยิ่งตุ๋นนานก็ยิ่งดีนะตุ๋นให้แบบ
คือวิวิธีการตุ๋นก็คือถ้าเป็นต้มเนี่ยเรา
จะใช้ไฟแรงๆเนาะแล้วก็ต้มไปเรื่อยๆแต่ถ้า
เป็นตุ๋นเนี่ยต้องไฟอ่อนๆลดไฟลงมาอาจจะไฟ
20% แล้วก็ใช้เวลานานๆนะให้มันแบบเข้าไป
ในเนื้อแล้วเนื้อไก่หรือเนื้อวัวเนื้อ
อะไรเนี่ยมันนิ่มมันนุ่มนะเขาคก็ใช้วิธี
การตุ่นหรือว่าเคี่ยวต่อไปจนแบบใช้เวลา
นานๆค่ะใช่ค่ะนะคะแล้วก็อันนี้ก็จะเป็น
เส้นข้าวซอยที่เราทำกันเมื่อสักครู่นี้นะ
เราจะแยกเป็น 2 ส่วนส่วนที่ 1 เนี่ยเรา
เอามาทอดให้มัน
กรอบอนะก็ทอดเหมือนเฟรนช์ไายเลยนักเรียน
ก็คือใส่น้ำมันเยอะหน่อยแล้วก็เอาเส้น
เนี่ยลงไปืลงไปมันก็จะพองขึ้นมาแล้วก็ฟู
ขึ้นมาแล้วเราก็ดุกลับด้านแล้วก็ตักขึ้น
เวลามันกรอบแล้วเนาะเราก็เอาขึ้นอ
นะให้มันเป็นสีลักษณะแบบเนี้ยค่ะนะใช่อีก
ส่วนนึงเนี่ยเราก็เอาไปลวกกับน้ำเดือดต้ม
จนเดือดเลยนะแล้วก็เอาไปลวกก็คือไปทำให้
แป้งมันนิ่มอ่ะสุกแล้วก็นิ่มใช่ก็คือ
เหมือนลวกเส้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวอ่ะลวกก็คือจะใช้
เวลาไม่นานจุ่มลงไปในน้ำเดือดๆอือพอเส้น
สุกแล้วเนี่ยเราก็สะบัดน้ำออก
นะเราก็มาราดกับแกงค่ะแกงมัสมั่นที่เรา
ที่เราทำนะราดลงไปที่เราต้มเสร็จแล้วนะ
เพราะฉะนั้นมันก็เลยจะมีเส้นที่เป็น 2
แบบนะเราก็จะเอาเส้นที่เราโต๊ะเราลวกนะ
เป็นนิ่มๆอ่ะใส่ลงไปก่อนแล้วก็นะใส่น้ำ
ราดน้ำแล้วก็อาจจะเป็นเนื้อไก่เนื้อนะ
แล้วก็ค่อยโรยข้างบนนะเป็นหมี่กรอบนะ
บหมี่กรอบแบบนี้อันที่ก็มักจะกิแล้วแล้ว
มักจะมีมะนาวนะสำหรับบีบสร้างความเปรี้ยว
ต้องใช้มะนาวไม่ใชไม่ค่อยนิยมใช้น้ำส้ม
สายชูใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ากลิ่นมันจะเข้ากับ
กะทิมากกว่าแล้วก็ต้องกินกับหอมแดงด้วย
มันจะอร่อยมากแล้วก็ต้องมีน้ำพริกเผานะ
เพิ่มความเผ็ดด้วยการใส่น้ำพริกเผานั่น
แหละค่ะเวลานักเรียนไปซื้อเนี่ยเค้าก็จะ
ใส่มาลักษณะแบบนี้นะก็คือเขาคจะใส่มาทั้ง
หมดแต่ถ้านักเรียนซื้อกลับบ้านเนี่ยเค้า
ก็จะใส่ถุงนะใส่ถุงพลาสติกใช่มั้ยแยกมา
เส้นที่ลวกเส้นที่ทอดนะแล้วก็ในเส้นที่
ลวกเนี่ยนะเส้นที่ลวกมาเนี่ยเขาก็จะใส่
พวกหอมแดงหรือบางคนเขาอาจจะแยกนะหอมแดงนะ
แล้วก็มีมะนาวมีพริกแยกให้พริกเผาแยกให้
นะเวลานักเรียนไปกินต้องกินด้วยกันค่ะนะ
แกงราดลงไปในเส้นเสร็จแล้วก็เอาทุกอย่าง
มาใส่แล้วก็ค่อยใส่มีกกรอบๆที่ทอดลงไป
แล้วก็กินด้วยกันมันจะอร่อยมากอืมทีเนี้ย
ข้าวซอยเราบอกว่าข้าวซอยเนี่ยเป็นอาหาร
ประจำชาติของทางเหนือก็จริงนะแต่ก็เอ่อ
ข้าวซอยทางเหนือเนี่ยก็มีการที่เอ่อแต่ละ
พื้นที่เนี่ยก็มีลักษณะที่แตกต่างกันนิด
หน่อยค่ะครูกุ๊กออย่างข้าวซอย
เชียงใหม่ก็เป็นแบบเชียงใหม่จะมีกลิ่น
เครื่องเทศนะคะแล้วก็จะกินกับผักกาดดอง
เอาผักกาดสีเียวๆเไปดองจนแบบออกรถเปรี้ยว
ๆนะก็ก็จะกินแบบใส่ผักกาดดองไม่ได้หอมแดง
เท่านั้นมีหอมแดงมีผักกาดดอง
นะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นแบบเอ่อหรือบางทีก็ทาน
คู่กับผักกะหล่ำหัวกะหล่ำอ่ะคะมาซอยซอยๆ
แล้วก็นะกินด้วยนะแต่ถ้าเป็นของจังหวัด
ลำปาง
นะลำปางเนี่ยจะใส่เครื่องเทศที่ไม่เหมือน
กัน
อืจะเป็นลูกกวาฬสีดำอ่ะจะใส่กวาฬสีดำนะค
อันเนี้ยเอ่อคนคนจีนยูนานจะเรียกอะไรนะ
ชะโกอะไรเนี่ยนะคะแล้วก็จะกินกับขิงค่ะ
แล้วก็กินกับลูกลูกผักชี
อือหือนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นสไตล์ของลำปาง
ถ้าเข้าซอยของจังหวัดเชียงรายเขาจะใส่
กะทิข้นๆจะข้นมากจะข้นมากกว่าที่
เชียงใหม่จะข้นมากกว่าที่ลำปางกินนะครส
ชาติจะหอมมีความเข้มข้นมากกว่า
นะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นลักษณะแบบทีเนี้ยเราบอก
แล้วไงทางเหนือใช่มยไม่ใช่ของยูนานแล้วก็
เชียงใหม่เชียงรายลำปางเท่านั้นนะพม่าก็
มีแล้วก็มาจาก
เอ่อไทยใหญ่ไทางด้านเหนือเนี่ยก็จะกิน
คล้ายๆกันจะมีการแตกต่างกันในเรื่องของ
รายละเอียดเล็กๆน้อยๆนะอย่างที่เราบอกนะ
ลักษณะการกินอย่างอย่างของที่อื่นอาจจะ
ไม่ได้ใส่กะทินะฮะของประเทศไทยเนี่ยจะใส่
กะทิแบบเนี้ยอืกะทิก็คือมาจากมะพร้าวค่ะ
นักเรียนอือหือนะเป็นมะพร้าวที่เราขูดเอา
เนื้อมะพร้าวมาแล้วก็ใส่น้ำร้อนแล้วก็
คั้นบีบออกมานะมันก็จะเป็นน้ำกะทินะน้ำ
กะทิแล้วก็เค้าก็จะแยกส่วนนึงอันแรกเนี่ย
มันจะมีความเข้มข้นนะมีครีมเยอะนะเป็น
ครีมเยอะมันก็จะเป็นหัวกะทินะส่วนน้ำที่ 2
อ่ะเคันออกมาเนี่ยความเข้มข้นมันจะน้อย
มันจะเป็นน้ำเยอะนะก็เป็นหางกะทิ
นะคิดว่าของทางเชียงรายครูชิบอกว่าเข้ม
ข้นมากกว่าอาจจะใส่แต่หัวกะทินะไม่ได้ใช้
หางกะทินะซึ่งถ้าเชียงใหม่เนี่ยจะไม่ข้น
เท่าก็อาจจะใส่หางกะทิลงไปด้วยนะน้ำมันก็
จะแบบไม่เข้มข้นมากไม่แบบไม่ได้แบบข้นมาก
อืนะแล้วก็อาหารที่เราบอกว่าติดอันดับ
เป็นอาหารเอ่อประเภทสตรูอันดับ 1 เนี่ยนะ
คถ้าเกิดเทียบกับอาหารอันดับโลกเนี่ยจะ
ได้อันดับ 10 ค่ะอืนะคนั่นก็คือ
พะแนงนพแนงพนงพแนงอนะจะเป็นเครื่องแกงแบบ
นี้นะนี่พแนงนะเวลานักเรียนไปตลาดหรือว่า
ไปแบบซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตเนาะเค้าก็จะมี
เครื่องแกงขายแล้วก็มีแต่ละชนิดเลยอยากทำ
แกงอะไรนะแกงเผ็ดนะแกงมัสสมั่นนะแกงเขียว
หวานนะก็จะมีเป็นแบบบอกไว้เลยว่าสำหรับ
อะไรนะถ้าไปตลาดแบบตลาดสดแบบคนไทยเค้าก็
จะมีขายเป็นแบบเยอะๆขายแล้วก็ชั่งตักแล้ว
ก็ชั่งเอานักเรียนอยากใช้เท่าไหร่ก็ซื้อ
นะก็ของพระแนงก็ก็มีก็ก็ไม่เครื่องก็ไม่
เยอะมากอ่ะุปุ๊กเพราะว่าพริกแกงเนี่ยซื้อ
สำเร็จได้อย่างที่ครุปุ๊กบอกแล้วก็มี
เนื้อหมูหรือจะเป็นมากๆก็กินหมูเออวัวไก่
ได้หมดเลยนะคะแล้วก็มีน้ำตาลปี๊บค่ะน้ำ
ตาลที่แบบเหนียวๆจับมะพร้าวอือใช่นะคะ
แล้วก็มีพริกชี้ฟ้ามีกะทิ
ที่สำคัญเนี่ยต้องมีใบมะกรูด
ค่ะใบมะกรูดนะใบมะกรูดนี่สำคัญจะทำให้
พแนงหอมอร่อยใช่แต่เขาจะไม่ได้ใส่เป็น
ชิ้นๆเหมือนต้มยำนะนักเรียนเต้องซอยเป็น
แบบเส้นเล็กๆละเอียดๆมันจะอร่อยกินได้ค่ะ
นี่ค่ะที่บอกตอนนี้เนี่ยนักเรียนสามารถ
ซื้อที่เป็นแบบสำเร็จได้ใช่มยมีขายเลยน้ำ
พริกแกงพแนงใช่ว่าไม่รู้ยี่ห้อไหนอร่อย
ที่สุดอนะตอนนี้ขายในซุเปอร์มาเกตด้วยนะ
อือฮึทำก็คล้ายๆกันนะเอากะทิลงไปใส่กระทะ
ก่อนแล้วก็แล้วก็เอาพริกแกงเนี่ยเอาไปผัด
ให้มีน้ำมันนะแล้วค่อยใส่เนื้อสัตว์ลงไป
แล้วก็ใส่ผักที่นักเรียนชอบนะแครอทจะใส่
หรือไม่ใส่ก็ได้บางคนชอบบางคนไม่ชอบก็ไม่
ต้องใส่นะแล้วก็ใส่พริกแดงหั่นใบมะกรูด
ซอยซอยเล็กๆนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นือเอทำแบบ
ใช่พแนงนะค
พแนง
ก็วันนี้นะนักเรียนก็ได้รู้จักวิธีการทำ
อาหารที่อร่อยมากๆนะนะเป็นอาหารทางภาค
เหนือของประเทศไทยเนาะนักเรียนก็มาประเทศ
ไทยก็มาแวะลองชิมลองกินดูว่าถูกใจนัก
เรียนมยเพราะว่ามีอันดับให้แล้วว่าติด
อันดับนะของโลกเช็คมาแล้วว่ามีคนโหวตให้
เยอะนะก็นะอาจจะเป็นที่ชื่นชอบของนัก
เรียนก็ได้นะแต่ว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยชอบมากค่ะ
ชอบอะไรคะพะแนงก็ชอบแต่เอ่อข้าซอยซมากๆ
ค่ะเห็นมั้ยครูปุ๊กกินข้าวซอยครูปุ๊กยัง
ต้องโหวตให้นะคะครูทิก็เหมือนกันครูชีก็
ชอบเข้าซอยเหมือนกันนะก็ต้องโหวตให้แล้ว
ครูชีเคิดว่านักเรียนหลายๆคนก็ชอบเช่น
เดียวกันนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมาแล้วก็นัก
เรียนลองชิมเนาะแล้วก็คอมเมนต์บอกเราด้วย
ว่านักเรียนรู้สึกว่ามันอร่อยหรือไม่
อร่อยยังไงนะถูกใจหรือไม่ถูกใจเนาะแล้วก็
คราวหน้าเรามาพบกันใหม่นะครูชิอาจจะมี
อะไรมาฝากอีกนะก็วันนี้ก็ขอบคุณครูชิมากๆ
ขอบคุณนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ